Avançons de dix ans, jusqu'en 2012,
j'arrivais comme principal dans ma 3ème école à faibles résultats.
J'allais être le quatrième principal de Strawberry Mansion en quatre ans.
Elle était étiquetée « peu performante et dangereuse »
à cause de ses faibles résultats aux tests
et du nombre élevé d'armes,
de la drogue, des agressions et des arrestations.
Peu après m'être approchée de ma nouvelle école,
avoir essayé d'entrer
et avoir trouvé la porte fermée par des chaînes,
je pouvais entendre la voix d'Ashley dans mes oreilles
disant : « Mademoiselle ! Mademoiselle !
Ce n'est pas une école. »
Les couloirs étaient ternes et sombres par manque de lumière.
Il y avait dans les salles de classe des tonnes
de fournitures et de bureaux cassés,
il y avait énormément de matériel et de ressources inutilisés.
Ce n'était pas une école.
Au cours de l'année,
j'ai remarqué que les classes étaient presque vides.
Les élèves étaient effrayés :
effrayés de s'asseoir dans les rangs de peur que quelque chose arrive,
effrayés car ils étaient souvent tourmentés à la cafétéria
car ils mangeaient gratuitement.
Ils avaient peur des bagarres et des brutalités.
Ce n'était pas une école.
Et puis, il y avait les professeurs,
qui avaient incroyablement peur pour leur propre sécurité,
donc ils avaient peu d'attentes des élèves et d'eux-mêmes,
ils ignoraient totalement leur rôle
dans le destruction de la culture de l'école.
Ceci était le plus dérangeant.
Vous voyez, Ashley avait raison
et pas seulement quant à son école.
Pour beaucoup trop d'écoles,
pour les enfants qui vivent dans la pauvreté,
leurs écoles ne sont vraiment pas du tout des écoles.
Mais cela peut changer.
Laissez-moi vous dire comment cela a été fait au lycée Strawberry Mansion.
Quiconque ayant déjà travaillé avec moi vous dira que
je suis connue pour mes slogans.
(Rires)
Alors aujourd'hui, je vais en utiliser trois
qui ont été primordiaux dans notre quête pour le changement.
Mon premier slogan est :
si vous devez diriger, dirigez.
J'ai toujours cru
que ce qu'il se passe ou non dans une école
dépend du principal.
Je suis le principal
et avoir ce titre exige de moi que je dirige.
Je n'allais pas rester dans mon bureau,
je n'allais pas déléguer mon travail,
et je n'allais pas avoir peur de régler quoi que ce soit
qui n'était pas bon pour les enfants,
peu importe si cela faisait de moi quelqu'un d'apprécié ou non.
Je suis une dirigeante,
donc je sais que je ne peux rien faire seule.
J'ai donc réuni une équipe de direction de premier ordre
qui croyait en la possibilité de tous les enfants
et, ensemble, nous nous sommes attaqués aux petites choses,
comme réinitialiser à la main toutes les combinaisons des casiers
afin que chaque élève puisse avoir un casier sûr.
Nous avons décoré tous les panneaux d'affichage du bâtiment
avec des messages joyeux, colorés et positifs.
Nous avons enlevé les chaînes de la porte principale.
Nous avons fait remplacer les ampoules
et avons nettoyé à fond toutes les salles de classe,
recyclant tous les livres qui n'étaient pas nécessaires
et nous débarrassant de milliers de vieux meubles.
Nous avons utilisé deux bennes par jour.
Et bien sûr, bien sûr,
nous nous sommes attaqués aux grosses choses
comme reprendre entièrement le budget de l'école
afin de pouvoir réallouer des fonds pour avoir plus de professeurs et de personnel.
Nous avons refait à partir de zéro l'emploi du temps de la journée
pour ajouter une variété d'heures de début et de fin,
de la réhabilitation, des cours d'honneur,
des activités parascolaires, de l'orientation professionnelle,
tout cela durant la journée d'école.
Tout cela durant la journée d'école.
Nous avons créé un plan de déploiement
qui spécifiait où chaque personne de soutien et officier de police serait
à chaque minute de la journée
et nous avons vérifié cela à chaque seconde de la journée,
et, notre meilleure invention,
nous avons élaboré un programme disciplinaire pour toute l'école
s'appelant « Non-négociables ».
C'était un système comportemental
créé pour promouvoir un comportement positif à tout instant.
Les résultats ?
Strawberry Mansion a été retiré de la liste des lycées dangereux
notre première année après --
(Applaudissements) --
après avoir été sur la liste des lycées dangereux durant cinq années consécutives.
Les dirigeants rendent possible l'impossible.
Cela m'amène à mon second slogan :
Et alors ? Et maintenant ?
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Quand nous avons regardé les données,
et que nous nous sommes réunis avec le personnel,
il y avait de nombreuses excuses
expliquant que Strawberry Mansion soit peu performante et dangereuse.
Ils disaient que seuls 68% des enfants venaient régulièrement à l'école,
100% d'entre eux vivent dans la pauvreté,
seul 1% des parents participent,
de nombreux enfants
sont issus de foyers monoparentaux ou ont un parent incarcéré,
39% des élèves ont des besoins spéciaux,
et les données de l’État ont révélé
que 6% des élèves étaient compétents en algèbre
et 10% en littérature.
Après qu'ils nous ont raconté toutes ces histoires
montrant combien les conditions et les enfants étaient horribles,
je les ai regardés
et j'ai dit : « Et alors ? Et maintenant ?
Qu'allons-nous faire à ce propos ? »
(Applaudissements)
Éliminer continuellement les excuses est devenu ma responsabilité première.
Nous avons confronté chacune de ces excuses
au cours d'un développement professionnel obligatoire,
pavant le chemin d'une concentration intense
sur l'enseignement et l'apprentissage.
Après de nombreuses observations,
nous avons déterminé que les professeurs savaient quoi enseigner
mais ne savaient pas comment enseigner
à tant d'enfants avec de si nombreuses capacités.
Nous avons donc développé
un modèle de transfert de connaissances pour l'instruction
qui se concentrait sur de petits groupes,
rendant possible pour chaque élève de satisfaire ses besoins individuels
en classe.
Les résultats ?
Après un an, les données de l’État ont révélé que
nos scores avaient augmenté de 171% en algèbre
et de 107% en littérature.
(Applaudissements)
Nous avons encore beaucoup de chemin à parcourir,
beaucoup, beaucoup de chemin,
mais nous approchons maintenant chaque obstacle
avec l'attitude du « Et alors ? Et maintenant ? ».
Cela m'amène à mon troisième et dernier slogan.
(Rires)
Si, aujourd'hui, personne ne vous a dit qu'il vous aimait,
souvenez vous que moi je vous aime, et que je vous aimerai toujours.
Mes élèves ont des problèmes :
des problèmes sociaux, émotionnels et économiques
que vous ne pourriez pas imaginer.
Certains d'entre eux sont eux-mêmes parents,
et certains sont complètement seuls.
Si quelqu'un me demandait mon vrai secret
sur comment je continue réellement à faire avancer Strawberry Mansion,
je dirais que j'aime mes élèves
et que je crois en leurs possibilités
de façon inconditionnelle.
Quand je les regarde,
je ne peux voir que ce qu'ils peuvent devenir
et cela parce que je suis l'une d'entre eux.
J'ai aussi grandi dans le nord pauvre de Philadelphie.
Je sais ce que c'est d'aller dans une école qui n'est pas une école.
Je sais ce que c'est de se demander
s'il y aura jamais une façon de sortir de la pauvreté.
Mais grâce à ma mère géniale,
j'ai pu rêver
malgré la pauvreté qui m'entourait.
Donc --
(Applaudissements) --
si je dois pousser mes élèves
vers leur rêve et leur but dans la vie,
je dois savoir qui ils sont.
Donc je dois passer du temps avec eux,
donc je surveille la cantine tous les jours.
(Rires)
Et quand j'y suis,
je leur parle de choses profondément personnelles,
quand c'est leur anniversaire,
je chante « Joyeux anniversaire »
même si je ne sais pas du tout chanter.
(Rires)
Je leur demande souvent :
« Pourquoi voulez-vous que je chante quand je ne sais pas du tout chanter ? »
(Rires)
Et ils répondent en disant :
« Parce qu'on aime se sentir spéciaux ».
Nous organisons mensuellement une réunion à la mairie
pour écouter leurs craintes,
pour découvrir ce qu'il y a dans leurs têtes.
Ils nous demandent : « Pourquoi devons-nous suivre des règles ? »
« Pourquoi y a-t-il tant de conséquences ? »
« Pourquoi ne pouvons-nous pas juste faire ce que nous voulons ? »
(Rires)
Ils demandent, et je réponds honnêtement à chaque question,
et cet échange dans l'écoute aide à dissiper les incompréhensions.
Chaque moment est riche en enseignements.
Ma récompense,
ma récompense
pour être non-négociable dans mes règles et mes conséquences
est leur respect gagné.
J'insiste là-dessus,
et à cause de cela, nous pouvons accomplir des choses ensemble.
Ils sont au clair quant à ce que j'attends d'eux
et je répète ces attentes tous les jours dans les haut-parleurs.
Je leur rappelle --
(Rires) --
Je leur rappelle ces valeurs fondamentales
de concentration, de tradition, d'excellence,
d'intégrité et de persévérance
et je leur rappelle tous les jours
combien l'éducation peut vraiment changer leur vie.
Et je clôture chaque annonce de la même façon :
« Si, aujourd'hui, personne ne vous a dit qu'il vous aimait,
souvenez-vous que je vous aime,
et que je vous aimerai toujours. »
Les mots d'Ashley :
« Mademoiselle ! Mademoiselle !
Ce n'est pas une école. »
sont pour toujours gravés dans mon esprit.
Si nous voulons vraiment faire un réel progrès
en s'attaquant à la pauvreté,
alors nous devons nous assurer
que chaque école où il y a des enfants dans la pauvreté
est une vraie école,
une école, une école --
(Applaudissements) --
une école qui leur fournit les connaissances
et l'entraînement mental pour naviguer dans le monde qui les entoure.
Je ne connais pas toutes les réponses,
mais je sais que pour ceux d'entre nous qui sont privilégiés
et qui ont la responsabilité de diriger une école
où il y a des enfants dans la pauvreté,
alors nous devons vraiment diriger,
et quand nous sommes confrontés à des défis incroyables,
nous devons nous arrêter et nous demander : « Et alors ? Et maintenant ?
Qu'allons-nous faire à ce propos ? »
Et tout en dirigeant,
nous ne devons jamais oublier
que chacun de nos élèves
n'est qu'un enfant,
souvent effrayé par ce que le monde lui dit qu'il devrait être,
et peu importe ce que le reste du monde leur dit sur ce qu'ils devraient être,
nous devrions toujours leur donner de l'espoir,
notre entière attention,
notre croyance indéfectible en leur potentiel,
des attentes constantes
et nous devons souvent leur dire
que si, aujourd'hui, personne ne leur a dit qu'il les aimait,
qu'ils se souviennent que nous les aimons et que nous les aimerons toujours.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Dieu merci.